Notice that team members who are more introverted in person...
...can really benefit from written communications.
Physical barriers can actually level the playing field...
...for those who may be less inclined to speak in group settings.
Lastly, find ways to celebrate and socialize remotely...
...to strengthen relationships between team members and improve collaboration.
Even a simple switch from conference calls to video, for instance,...
...can boost rapport and create empathy.
The challenges of remote teams will not disappear,...
...but creating consistent rules, rituals and protocols will go a long way..
...in building a new communication skill set.